[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by car shop.com
you don't have to be a freeloader your
whole life the good news is that you can
support this show and the fight by
buying some really cool clothes.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
i'm increasing my lung capacity my
little test goes
says you're not dying hey that's good so
i'm getting better with my sips so i
hate watching that intro where i can see
myself back when i had uh uh perceived
muscle
today i was in the gym and i tried to do
a row and i act i actually audibly went
and the guy next to me said
he kicked your ass are you transitioning
in a rouse i said no this is just har
and i stopped did the lunk alert go off
at the planet fitness again i don't go
there but sure the wussy alert went off
yes they said sir it's far too
embarrassing you have to leave uh we
can't have members with no self-respect
and i said that's fair that's fair
that's why i belong there yes yes
we all have lifelong memberships and
they've been revoked that is an ego
killer hey i have a question for you
before we move on you guys can comment
below what did you do yesterday when
facebook and ig they call instagram the
ig there dave i noticed that when the
egg went down
what did you guys do and is it just one
of those coincidences we'll be talking
about that we'll be talking about look
later on and we have a video coming up
later this week where um quarterblack
garrett knows this we went down we
interviewed a bunch of wealthy white
people yeah about masks and uh mask
mandates vaccine mandates and then we
went to an area where was predominantly
uh uh people of color and asked them
about it two very very different answers
but we talked about natural immunity and
nobody knew about it and it's something
that we have not been allowed to talk
about on youtube
except for the fact that now it's been
admitted undercover uh from the pfizer
scientists and now we have studies from
israel that shows surprise it works
better
that's weird so we're going to be
talking like this is important because
this is something everybody needs to
know if our interest right here in this
country is to get back to normal if our
if our our interests right here if
they're aligned we want everyone to be
protected that needs to be taken into
account and unfortunately the media and
some of these companies have been lying
to you about it which tells you that
maybe our interests aren't aligned okay
before we go on to that we'll also be
talking about joe biden wiping his took
us uh gerald how are you i'm still sick
hoping i'm getting natural immunity as
we speak
me too we'll do blood brothers with a
popsicle stick okay afterwards cool and
how are you i have to ask how are you
well aside from that
you're you're okay okay i mean it's a
relative you do something manly
afterwards to kind of cancel it out like
uh well i did i did beat up a school
great girl who mocked ah yes i don't
know again she was at the daycare center
of the gym i just walked in i knocked
over a few blocks popping right in the
nose special needs toughens them up i
don't want her playing tick-tock gender
pronouns quarterback aaron how are you
yo what's up what's going on oh you feel
like you have a you have a beanie so you
have to do the voice i don't know what
you're talking about oh okay no clue all
right had a good weekend though it's a
good weekend yeah good weekend no scythe
cells no sling blade cells no some
people call it a sickle cell i call it a
sling blade cell and uh regular girls
dave landau is here how are you i'm good
ahoy good you're you're my looking
chipper i am i'm chipper i'm up you have
uh you have a show coming up too a
replacement by the way in kansas uh
november 11th at the cotillion in
wichita you can go to cotillion.com with
a link down below because you had to
swap out the show because another place
they were a bunch of fascists yes that's
correct this place is not right and this
place yeah it looks like they get really
great bands i saw they had stone temple
pilots so i know that most of that band
will be there
very nicely scott wylin may not make it
but the rest of them should have been
tipped off when the other booker was
named mr pol pot
yes should have been dead giveaway venue
before we move on though this is
something that's been going on and by
the way we'll be talking later this uh
the predator look-alike is uh
whistleblowers
i guess testifying before the senate
right now so we'll talk about that a
little bit later on you guys can send us
your chat if you're a member of mug club
and uh let us know what it is you want
us to address uh but first this is going
on on tock uh a leftist teacher
uh tried to teach a bunch of preschool
kids
nursery rhymes oh which is why i have to
hit them
about masks here you go
two three
i
wear a mask to school
i wear a mask to school rough start hi
ho the jerry
i frame dresser
wear a mask
to keep me safe
it helps to keep me safe
hi ho the derry-o
oxygen levels 11.
it keeps my friends safe
hi ho the dairy the kids are like
whatever lady my friends safe and let me
see a hooray put your hands up in the
air
that looks like kids at a birthday party
of a rich kid that they don't like but
there's an ice cream truck
easiest thing in the world is to get
kids to scream and they're like yeah
whatever
whatever
you could have just incorporated some
kind of sweets into the nursery rhyme
and they would have cheered and your
propaganda would be that much more
effective hey just like yesterday with
cinema people understand this we've
again have we've had videos removed yeah
and project veritas has for privacy
violations it's illegal to film children
without their parents consent yes it's
illegal to film people in the bathroom
it's perfectly legal to film people or
to record audio in single party consent
states if they are adults
not relieving themselves in the bathroom
and you can't film children but again
these big tech companies don't actually
follow the laws that exist and they
create new ones it is a lawless lawless
place where dreams go to die
i was wondering about that because a
comic well i don't want to call him that
but some guy years ago
filmed himself playing a filthy song
then caught it with a class that he was
substitute teaching and i believe he
went to jail
jail time
for this and this is fun with him more
egregious
sing us a song yeah give us a dice clay
how about you sing us a song about old
macdonald yeah it'll make it go better
old macdonald had a fanny the wheels on
the gurney go round and round round and
round round and round cause a kid didn't
wear a mask
now the horn on the hearse goes beep
beep
old macdonald had a mask e-i-e-i-o and
on top of the mask he had a vaccine
e-i-e-i-o and he died from a
breakthrough breakthrough case e-i-e-i-o
went to the doctor and the doctor said
was a brain hemorrhage with mark to
covert instead
we can keep doing this
black sheep please take the vaccine
why not why not most white sheep did
i don't know what to do i'm racially
uncomfortable so i'll just ignore it uh
you know ringing around the rosie an
actual kid's rhyme was actually about
the the plague right yeah a pocket full
of poses yeah like i don't even know
that it was flowers that they would
stuff in your pocket so you wouldn't
smell as bad ring around the rosie was
actually like how your face would look
like literally they made a children's
rhyme about people dying oh poor rose of
place it was good times you can bring it
up if we if we can before the end of the
day we'll have it i just want to make
sure that i'm accurate is posie the beak
like remember the beak mask that like oh
yeah
they would wear is that what it was yeah
it was posies like flower right yeah and
they filled it with potpourri
and you know so they
somebody started a fire in london and it
looks like we're not dying anymore oh
dressed like the costume ball and
labyrinth yes this wasn't
her medically sealed
and just beat yourself some more and pay
your penance and god will forgive you
oh my gosh all right i did so god has
not forgiven us uh look at the world
no i kept thinking yesterday boy i'm
just glad so many people i loved are
dead yeah i really i'm not even kidding
no i i just there's so many people i
wouldn't want to see this when you when
you read about sodom and gomorrah you're
like
that's pretty mild yes like really
he turned them to salt for that have you
seen what goes on just across the bridge
from oakland have you seen uh may i
present to you las vegas yes oh that's
the that's like normal miles
yeah yeah what happens in gamora stays
in gamora yeah las vegas is like gay
magicians that's as crazy as it gets
now i'm gonna watch i'm going to make
this man's consent form disappear
hey
they said if god doesn't judge america
he owes sodom and gomorrah and apollo
yes he does
we're just asking for some consistency
[Laughter]
we went to go see david copperfield yeah
whenever he makes women disappear from
the audience
he has a type
and it was two blonde women with big
breasts who then were uh seen on his
private island not long after now it's
not an epstein thing it's consent but
he's like i'm gonna make uh two of you
in the audience disappear and i'm ah i
have a wave he's like
you
wow thank you
they just ended up roofied in his room
well he got accused of uh sexual assault
did he yeah he did i think i believe the
charges were dropped but i guess
he made the nine and one buttons on her
phone disappears
well where is it in uh in uh where is it
now is it uh in austin also the
three-in-one buttons you know all the
ways for non-emergency is that true yeah
yeah in austin i mean technically you're
not supposed to call the pl but this
includes things like your car has just
been robbed or you don't know if
someone's robbing your house not an
emergency oh nothing serious yeah
nothing serious there's a guy in my
house but i'm not sure if he's going to
stab me or masturbate so if you're not
sure
if you're not in it just don't go in the
house yeah that's true
they i assume they have to do that in
new york because i look if you have
children i would say okay three two just
giving you a warning there no one if
you've lived in new york for a certain
amount of time has not been masturbated
masturbated upon in the subway that's
true what we've all had a little bit
it's very uncommon
i'm telling you i'm sorry i've tried i
lived in like yes
the first the first couple of months you
live in manhattan and you take the
subway you know you dress you look like
a zera ad you're dressed fashionably and
then by month six everyone looks like
paddington bear
really true just wear like a raincoat
yes
there's do they have a mist station that
you go in and just
i took a video of spider-man crawling on
the ceiling of the train i was on nice
and no one caring at all it's everyone
just looking down
at their farms like anywhere else on
earth that would seem strange yeah but
there they're like well at least he's
not masturbating yes
he has clothes on it that's a weird web
who knows
who knows you do your thing oh wait
there's a pile of crap just uh let's
just put caution tape around it yeah
don't actually clean it how many people
though have did you see when you live in
new york using the bathroom just on the
subway at least what a dozen oh i can't
it looks kind of yeah
why don't you just beat the crap out of
them sorry i'm not that defeated
and somebody tries to punch them well it
just could be a mess yeah exactly that's
the point he grabs the whole it's a
great defense
that's like the crab revealing his red
underside oh it must be poisonous only
once you see him make this face
you cut him away
don't go close the point is new york's a
hell hole and so is san francisco and uh
it's not a coincidence hey speaking of
uh going to the bathroom
so remember yesterday we were talking
about uh senator uh cinema and if i say
systema just know it's just in my head
for some reason because the stem is like
the french it's like some french combat
part that doesn't work the point is i
may accidentally mispronounce it all
right um unfortunately here's the thing
she was followed in the bathroom which
is illegal right just like filming
little kids yes
turns out i don't know when it gets to
stalking turns out that it was not the
first encounter yeah at all and it's
amazing to see you know you always
wondered what the what would it take for
the democrats the left to condemn people
in their own ranks you would think
following someone in to take a dump and
filming them which is illegal a gross
violation of privacy uh would suffice
not with the president we'll get that to
that in a second but this woman has been
followed uh quite a bit cinema here you
go here here are the other times uh we
uh have a montage
we need solutions in the buildback
better plan need us the solutions that
we need we knocked on doors for you to
get you elected and just how we got you
elected we can get you out of office if
you don't support what you promised us
ah it's bilingual stalking
she brought it on herself
i hope this isn't in austin
you can explain to the american people
what you're planning on cutting from joe
biden's build-up interview
do you want to collect climate
priorities is it elder care that you
want to cover
maybe she has a shiv and you might find
yourself uh
on the flight
i don't know if you remember me i just
want to know if um
you can comment as my senator as you if
you can commit
to passing
a reconciliation how did you get in that
seat
provide a pathway to citizenship
for
immigrants
by the way can we pause that pause it
pause it uh
justin senator cinema just lost 100 000
instagram followers oh
lost
like she's game keeps happening oh man i
just started liking her just then yeah
i have an honest question now just be
clear not her policies no no no no well
no it depends on her two of them two
yeah i have an honest question that
person on the plane i think is the same
person in the video that's in the
bathroom illegal immigrant yeah right
and she also said you're my senator
right do you understand what that
implies yes that she voted illegally
yeah
what's your point
how many times though
like
oh oh you seem super you seem surprised
i seem very surprised oh all right how
did she get on a plane like what
identification did you yeah
no no that's right just accused usa of
being racist oh and they were like go
ahead it's fine i don't need to go to
the machine is it because i'm latinx no
no no no no no go go ahead you can go go
around the ropes yes okay that's good my
system is still works i'm gonna go ask
this lady some questions i don't have to
pay for tsa pre we know at least one
illegal vote in arizona just saying
there might be more at least possibly
one at least one and people say hey you
think we should deport these people
so uh
just no proof now that anybody that was
illegal helped him run there's no
there's no proof whatsoever and it's not
like that's an admission of guilt that
she went out and campaigned for him and
voted for him but is afraid that she
can't go back to mexico because she may
not be able to come back to the united
states despite the fact that of course
mexico is uh
uh equal equal
they're dreamers drinking oh they're not
screamers
oh so they're uh they're fillings
they're understudies for les mis so to
drink
it's a small dream but one thing i have
a dream a dream
i'm curious did they actually do do
dreamers get the right to vote um well
like if the the dreamer act like
basically said you get full citizenship
right just kind of at the end
you mean how many times well yeah well
they go back through like a revolving
door and they say you've already voted
and they say one more time they're
saying no they're and they're
undocumented oh okay so that's what i
thought i didn't think the dreamer thing
had fully happened i think that was well
they want it to happen yeah that was the
dream happened yeah i don't know yet but
i don't know different dream who would
dream of going to the united states when
all countries are equal you have
acapulco
that's a nice place yeah
i like cancun
because i'm into [ __ ] stamps and
yardstick drinks
i'm into white trash on vacation yeah i
just love garbage people yes i like to
witness sexual assault for a weekend
yeah
exactly
well come on have you ever been dave's
more of a watcher it's all inclusive but
in the loosest sense of the world well
yeah it's very yeah it means they
include the things that will get you so
inebriated that you pay for the other
things right i know i went there when
they had the climate summit just in case
you know that they weren't taking it
seriously i wish we had the climate
summit you know the one where ted turner
said yeah
china's won policies i know let's uh
what's skype let's all fly to cancun
where the climate summit to [ __ ] about
uh carbon emissions of course
uh
former vice president joe biden was
asked about this and this is what i
would call a layup right hey what do you
think about them following a sitting
senator into the bathroom harassing her
breaking the law this is an easy oh well
just condemn it so that you can assume
the moral high ground but of course uh
he didn't take uh the freebie mr
president you're talking about how you
have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two
have been pressured over the weekend by
activists joe manchin had people on
kayaks show up to his boat tl adam
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to
people who have secret service stand
around them
um so uh it's it's it's part of the
process
it actually happens to quite literally
no but what happens to two people
happens to larry craig and this person
and he took a wide stance took a power
stance when he would go to the bathroom
it's nice and maybe former vice
president joe biden just thinks it's
normal for people to follow you into the
bathroom because he's one of the few
people who actually has a team of folks
following men to wipe his ass
[Music]
notice he didn't say
i wiped my butt yeah no it has been
wiped someone else did that for him yeah
so when he's not emptying his colostomy
bag he's having other people wipe him
also when he goes to the restroom at a a
public restaurant you can see that he
the door is swinging open and close and
you can hear him say i'm all done
[Laughter]
i made a poopy she was making that
speech just cut and all the reporters
were in kayaks
[Laughter]
it must be those land kayaks you know
the funniest thing is that when they
were trying to come up with what he
actually said to like spin it he was
like no no he said what what's been what
like that was out of my butt
i heard it i saw him say my butt's been
wiped
what what what it has been
it's like we all have butts what
everybody poops come on what are we
doing he either hired somebody to be his
own personal bidet or he doesn't know
how to speak the english language and
he's president which is just a dreamer
with a fire hose
a super soaker works well as a
bidet yeah yes i would prefer the jet
stream this morning instead of the mist
yeah if you're just not if you can't
afford a big day right it's just a
dreamer with a super soaker especially
when you can go around corners oh and
i'm not looking at you and oh surprise i
never had you say it's essential i wish
oh it's essential it's essential
childhood twist hey by the way before we
move on it's a podcast you can subscribe
on apple spotify android uh we when we
were banned from youtube for a couple of
weeks a lot of you went over there so
just use it as a backup i know you want
to watch it of course mug club is the
best place to watch like today we'll be
playing uh the bad movie lines an extra
hour of the show and the best way to
tune in if you're watching on youtube
it's live monday through thursday 10am
eastern uh and of course just leave a
comment and hit the like button uh
andrew yang is in the news he is huh
awesome again cool guys in a while he
announced on a blog post that he would
be leaving the democrats
to be a moderate
but said that you shouldn't i don't know
so let me just read what he wrote at
andrew yang.com i changed my voting
registration from democrat to
independent today it was a strangely
emotional experience please keep in mind
that i am not suggesting that you also
change your voter registration to
independent as i have done
doing so could disenfranchise you if you
live in the 83 of the country that is
very blue
or very
red uh
i don't i don't i don't understand what
it is like do not as i do do as i say
but you also are saying that the
democrat party is corrupt and beyond
repair yeah i also don't understand how
he thinks the full country is 166
yes exactly but he's not a math asian
yeah not one of
he's more of a whipped cream and jello
shots yeah that's true marva falling off
a skateboard asian yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm just laughing because he thinks he's
still relevant and anybody cares like
he's like hey guys i'm leaving
people millions of democrats out there
they are going to miss his promise for
endless free money well yes
um
for ubi that's true
he is one of those people that ran on
i'll give you a thousand bucks via vote
i'm not bribing you or anything yeah
that's right what about anything else
look all right come on a thousand bucks
a month okay a month that's pretty good
we're good
get yourself a weber some steaks
that'll work out you dreamers can get
yourself some i don't know what an el
camino you drive i don't know whatever
you need to chase people into the
bathroom at all hours of the day
whatever your dreamers do i see me at
least
come on yeah i look cool
did it was like huh look at that
so uh it is time for the democrats at
least and the big money and the free
money the people who supported free
money for andrew yang and the democratic
party uh it is time to close mr yang
your your signature policy is to give
every adult in the united states one
thousand dollars a month no questions
asked that's right uh
i think that's like 3.2 trillion dollars
a year
how would you do that
[Music]
sorry time to
close
[Music]
endings and beginnings are ending and
beginning now
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are getting
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i just like to see him in that uh
whipped cream bikini like varsity blue
yeah
i have a problem with guys willing to
hit the floor and open their mouths so
quickly
he seems like the kind of guy who would
like die in a drunken car crash and his
bros would have a roadside memorial
yeah
the shitty teddy bear they got at the
airport just with this with this you
know like a licensed plate with his
initials yeah just nothing too much yeah
could have been a bunch of his black
friends would have a t-shirt with him on
him yeah oh yeah you got to get it done
right here
they all just say yang gang in that
ridiculous spot
don't worry he's he's still alive and
well and scouring the country for
another election to lose yes yes
absolutely i wish him luck he is like
the little asian that could only
couldn't
i'm the worst athlete on earth and i can
hit a ball
like he swung the bat and just spun yeah
he's like i don't know there's going to
be motion right yeah nuts i've seen like
a tasmanian devil yeah
yeah i just didn't even get close
uh all right
so this ball will be thrown at me yeah
wow i've never heard of this hey pete
how do you handle the balls coming at
you yeah well
gerald come on sorry carol it was too
far man
yeah i don't like it
too much so uh hey speaking of uh too
much the george floyd mural
was defaced just uh four days after its
debut wow uh it was in new york city to
be clear um it was defaced with gray
paint by a teen on a skateboard and it
was actually caught on tape
he just does it so matter-of-factly that
lady's like is he is can you do that
they don't even know how to react is is
he is he fixing it is he what is he is
he sprucing it up oh
huh
he says no one does anything
in new york people are so used to crime
they're just like
that's just i guess this is happening
and they do nothing basically it's just
a drive-by money shot
effectively and by the way um there's
actually a photo of the vandal now in a
close-up
uh they've asked you to alert him
immediately if you have any tips
on the
that is that
that is that him that's the picture
that's the guy yeah really
unedited huh hey uh
hey corner black um
uh where where were you on where were
you on sunday
i was visiting some friends in
new york
oh
where about
uh i mean is that pain on your hands
this yeah no i was i was working on a
project okay all right you know okay
let's let's cut the crap we know okay we
know it was you yeah we know you know
what frankly i couldn't be prouder well
oh well it's just a coincidence okay
well look just for standing up and what
he believes in uh yeah yeah
i
we have a tip line people from new york
you can send it and we have a link in
the description yeah
uh speaking of uh coincidences uh we
actually have uh a segment here on and
they're doing a a
testimony right now in front of the
senate but we actually have a segment
curious coincidences that we do here uh
because of course we're not allowed to
connect any dots otherwise you know we
could be banned um but
coincidences for which there is no
correlation right in daily life that are
inexplicable it's almost like the
x-files oh
only for coincidences that would you
know that would seem
actually entirely probable time for uh
crazy coincidences
[Music]
okay so yesterday we talked about and
actually you can bring her up right here
she's uh talking right now
like healthy recipes to anorexia
promoting content over a very short
period of time and has facebook ever
found again in its research that kids
show sign
of addiction on instagram i don't know
she's never studied a pattern that they
call problematic use
you were in the tanning salon with those
crappy little
did you hit eyewear
sprinkle freckle button yes
several times
each one is a kiss from an angel
fallen but the point remains um so her
name is is it francis francis hogan
anyway
yesterday we covered uh she's the
facebook whistleblower
hollywood francis we uh covered the bs
claim she was making that facebook
wasn't doing enough to combat hate
speech right january 6th right again
beware the trojan horse here there's a
reason that this whistleblower is
favored there's a reason that for
example when we had antifa on camera
with sawed-off shotguns and ice picks
and threatening to kill ben shapiro that
nothing was done about it there's a
reason that they love this whistleblower
not the whistleblowers with receipts
from facebook who show that there were
codes embedded into conservative pages
to actually throttle them so be clear if
the media is making this girl their
darling
there's a reason for it okay don't let
the sleight of hand fool you that being
said
something else that did come up
uh in the interview on 60 minutes on
sunday but wasn't exclusive to this and
again was ignored by the media when ted
cruz did it but we'll show it first uh
here is she said that facebook and ig
the kids call instagram the ig egg yeah
yeah guy g um that they were preying on
the insecurities and suicidal thoughts
of teenage girls to drive more traffic
to the platform here's a clip from 60
minutes of her saying it one of the
facebook internal studies that you found
talks about how instagram harms teenage
girls oh yeah
one study says 13 and a half percent of
teen girls say instagram makes thoughts
of suicide worse
17 of teen girls say instagram makes
eating disorders worse what is watching
super tragic is facebook's own research
says
as these young women
begin to consume this eating disorder
she looks like viggo the carpathian
that actually makes them use the app
more
and so they end up in this feedback
cycle where they hate their bodies more
and more facebook's own research says
it's not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers that it harms
teenagers
it's that it is distinctly worse than
other forms of social media yeah no you
think it's because you and i understand
i don't work in the show but they shot
his singles afterward where he's like
yeah
he's putting his glasses in his mouth
like
go on
i'm actually listening to you mass teen
suicide you say oh no
she had man hands just cut back to me as
a pirate eye patch
[Laughter]
[Music]
but here's the thing she made that
comment however this is a comment that
this is something that's been discussed
quite a bit
have you ever heard uh the and this is a
long clip but i want you to watch the
entire context because it wasn't just
it's super duper bad but senator ted
cruz uh actually grilled uh someone who
worked at uh i believe at facebook one
of these big tech platforms i don't know
if she works with instagram we'll have
it up here uh on the clip yeah it's hard
to keep track of the uh the satanic
forces against the little bit uh
it's straight i'm a human nobel prize
winning for humans so ah
that being said i'm kind of [ __ ]
so where are we where have we heard it
before senator ted cruz only he drilled
down and gave specifics it's a longer
clip if you haven't seen this you need
to here you go one of the things the
wall street journal reported
was that mark zuckerberg was personally
and directly aware of that research
is that correct
senator
mark pays attention to a lot of the
impact research that we do
and i would i don't know whether he was
aware of the specific piece of research
but i know that he's looking at the
research as we all are i i work with the
research teams on a weekly basis a daily
basis actually um in relation to
to the uh safety and security of the
people on our planet that's a non-answer
all right so you said you weren't going
to plead ignorance okay a minute ago you
said that this research was and i wrote
it down because the phrase really jumped
out at me you said this is not
bombshell research
uh i i found that a a pretty remarkable
statement
um
the wall street journal reported that
your facebook research concluded that 13
percent of british users and six percent
of american users trace their desire to
kill themselves to instagram and and has
the full research been released or not
actually senator we've released two of
the specific studies and we're looking
to release more research so what is the
research you haven't released what are
you keeping secret because you're
telling us if only you knew the full
research and then at the same time
you're not releasing the research so so
which is it
i understand your question do you want
us to examine the full research or not
at least to the primary sources we're
trying to release others i believe you
have so you've cherry-picked the ones
you want us to see have you released the
research i haven't seen this research so
if you've released it i will happily
take a look at it have you released the
research that the wall street journal
said concluded and this is your own
researcher concluding
13 percent of british users and 6
percent of american users trace their
desire to kill themselves to instagram
have you released the underlying and the
the entire underlying research behind
very specific question
please senator again i disagree with the
characterization of the research in the
wall street have you released the entire
research behind it have you released the
research behind it
the entire research
we've released the two studies as i
guess
the only reason about blowing my head
off right now is because i don't want to
lose water as a sponsor
it's too far away and you're not on
instagram as much
think about this for a second you have
this this this this day who's up there
doing the testament this super it's a
super duper problem
i don't think i understand the question
these people are they're not only in
they're in charge of all information
they're your engineers they're designing
your vaccines and your planes
and they're
they're making you want to die yeah
apparently well
allegedly because we don't have the
research so this happened yesterday
flowers behind her teen's funeral yeah
exactly
she she got it at crappy kitchen designs
they were going to throw it out yeah
they're not going to use them anymore i
just there's 13 more now and i like
flowers right
so by the way at the time that our show
ended yesterday when we were talking
about this and the facebook story the
whistleblower blew up uh 12 p.m eastern
began trending that facebook and its
subsidiaries instagram the ig
and whatsapp went down globally remained
down again for six
hours happened right after the story
blew
uh
i just
uh
interesting weird
[Music]
i think i think mark lost like seven to
ten billion dollars in net worth
yesterday yeah like a bad day no no i'm
being dead seriously i know well
unbelievable zuckerberg yeah well there
is no other mark dude owes me 12.50
by the way this is just the perfect
example when you see the left they they
[ __ ] about billion billionaire
corporations or multi-billion dollar
corporations how corrupt they are you
know why that's you guys the mom and pop
business down the street and by the way
when i say mom and pop i do mean
businesses that are doing 50 million
dollars a year in revenue 100 million
dollars a year in gross revenue they're
not out there deliberately abusing a
system and causing global harm knowingly
to just squeeze out a few extra dollars
yeah this is the the reason that jeff
bezos the reason that mark zuckerberg
believed that all billionaires are
horrible human beings is because they
was because of them
they're horrible here mirror on the wall
who's the biggest [ __ ] i didn't even
have to finish the sentence did i it's
just you interrupted
i was the i the only person that looked
at instagram and was like oh my phone's
not working and then didn't care and
then found out the world ended to half
the people
on the planet what's going on how do
like what's gonna happen if the internet
ever shuts down
you know people aren't even gonna know
how to walk to a restaurant no they're
not gonna know how they can't find a
restaurant there's this weird fabric
with lines on a map oh well i guess if
that's what you want to call it that's
what it's called it's a map you can
follow it
and by the way when they're talking
about how it's only women wanting to
kill themselves have you look men
comment below have you been on instagram
you're like if guys are seeing a record
number of men on there with abs on their
on their pecker we don't throw ourselves
out of window yeah
i don't even know what workout you do
how hard it is to gain muscle and lean
down women a lot of them get implants of
course on facebook when we're talking
about the unrealistic standards the
instagram models right butt implants
breast implants the men are teeming with
anabolic steroids and then trying to
tell you that it's from their yerba mate
tea the point is it goes both ways we're
not one smoothie away from one direction
here no i love seeing a perfect ten who
i think would look at me as if i was
invisible right every five minutes
thrown in my face oh yes another person
another one okay everything about social
media is depressing it's designed to
it's the best part of everybody's life
being shown to you airbrushed everything
it's it's designed to make you feel
insecure because it's designed as a
platform to get you to buy stuff yeah to
make you feel more secure it's all it is
we're just trapped in it now do you
remember when gold digger used to be
considered pejorative yes now women go
yeah well if you donate to my amazon
wishlist sure yeah no that's a healthy
relationship to buy a complete stranger
expensive gifts in the hope of filling
this god-shaped hole in my soul right
well it's the same as like half the
female comedians that do only fans right
it's like so that's like yeah i have
this great ping-pong ball act and i
stand up
but it really it's just it's crazy so
talented though have you seen me play
the harmonica
the whistleblower actually had an only
fans i don't know if you guys what
really what's that or what oh
well see that just makes me feel bad
about me so i'm going to have abs like
that see it's just impossible you're one
sexy mother oh she sees this heat
oh yes gosh well look in better news at
least all the millennials couldn't eat
because they couldn't take pictures of
their food to post on instagram so this
one's strong but then it's
a vicious cycle because then it's the
anorexic stuff on the instagram she's
arnold's maid
it comes out with like talent
why does my son look like predator
without the mask just big-headed bret
that was awesome that was the extended
cut you didn't you didn't get to see
that from predator one all right well
we'll go we'll probably watch more of
this uh on on mug club because the
problem is here's the thing if someone
says something on cnn right now on cnn
hey look one second it's amy klobuchar
the woman who said that election
security was the biggest threat in
democracy and co-signed a letter she was
bernie sanders and with elizabeth warren
and then said ah
we were wrong my result for five years i
was wrong about that let me hear what
she has to say in her helmet cut they
found out that their algorithms are
fostering polarization why do you go
into a barber shop and ask for the
princeton
they allow 99
of their violent contact to remain
unchecked on their platform including
lead up to the january
come on what did they do
they now as we know mark zuckerberg is
going sailing and saying no apologies
i think the time has come for action and
i think you are the catalyst for that
action um you have said privacy
legislation hey guys let's be clear
let's just bring up have someone in the
control room just search for anything
any article to this effect she just said
you know violence how many times has the
left said that speech is violent
you've heard it and changed my mind
you've seen them in articles that vox
yeah today
it's like you just like mcdonald's how
many served with that stupid
equivocation happens all the time and
now she's saying the violence well guess
what we've been accused on facebook of
violence yeah do you know there was an
article that actually courtney i co it
was about beyonce when beyonce was
complaining that because it was of her
race and i think the article is called
dear beyonce it's not because you're
black it's because you're a [ __ ]
and it had gifts every time of her like
it would have gifts of her complaining
about and i had gifts of her like like
humping the air and like humping a desk
like the reason americans don't want you
performing for their daughters look you
can do that in the strip club but this
has nothing to do with your race this
speech could be interpreted as
violence what i would really love to see
too is if we can do some research on
this how many times did amy klobuchar go
out there during the summer of love as
we have been told to call it when people
were burning down buildings people were
getting shot stabbed beaten in mass
officer casualties were crazy billions
of dollars in damage was she out there
saying that hey we need to stop the
violence on facebook now right like in
that time or is it just the the worst
attack on the capital in history other
than the several bombings that have
happened there no she was out in
chinatown with pelosi playing the back
of the dragon
yeah
it's an important part if you don't play
the back it doesn't matter who plays the
front still matters this isn't little
rascals
yeah searching the internet so she looks
like tim allen's wife on home
improvements
[Applause]
i want i need a pantsuit
damn i said i didn't want to do that
like oh how'd you get this job
by the way you made a really good point
a serious point on this one when i said
not that
definitely something else i love it when
he goes oh that's uh that's what made
him a star it's a calling card don't you
wish you started standing for the 90s
you'd be a god
so this this this is really trojan horse
like this is gaslighting this is saying
facebook has to be stopped because
they're not doing enough to silent
speech so now every time somebody brings
up the social media argument it's going
to be in this vein because that's all
you're saying and here's the thing what
they're not saying is enforce the law
notice that no one is saying hey on
these platforms you followed a woman
into a bathroom right that's illegal hey
on these platforms you allowed children
in a vaccination propaganda piece to be
shown on camera that's illegal when we
have people who give consent with whom
we conduct an interview and then they
don't like the direction of the video we
will have our stuff taken down this has
happened in the past so no one here is
saying hey you need to enforce the law
they're saying oh look can we give you
more unfettered power to
to censor violence by the way speech is
violence beware the trojan horse
just be aware of that i think it's
horrible that girls feel bad about
themselves yeah i think it's horrible if
guys feel bad about themselves don't
look at the answer remember when people
used to say this about south park when
they used to say it and by the way i uh
there was an interview with matt stone
and i asked him some questions it was at
ut austin he said we never really were
at war with christians they didn't want
us on
during the day and they said matt stone
so we didn't want to be under the day we
wanted to be on at night we don't think
it's a kid's show right yeah so he's
like so but the truth is the problems we
have with people like tip or gore you
know the rating system right yeah right
remember the argument usually we'll just
flip the channel
flip the channel don't go to instagram
if it makes you feel bad about yourself
now i understand if they're targeting
children however hey how about enforcing
the law youtube hardcore gay pornography
that's child friendly guys playing
dicker dildo that's child friendly but
if we quote the cdc it gets tagged as
misinformation and over 18 plus one is
illegal kids are not to have access to
hardcore
pornography which you have a mass but if
we say something that you don't like
that gets ripped because speech could be
violence no one on the left is saying i
would love that follow the laws enforce
the laws how about that that's the
litmus test no no don't create new laws
enforce the laws yeah and absolutely so
i think too this it feels like to me i
don't know if it feels like to you guys
dave and steve i don't know if this
feels like cover right saying that this
is harming young girls yes it's harming
them oh and by the way this is also
violent content it feels like oh that's
the thing everybody can get behind why
would you argue against making sure that
people don't kill themselves because
they feel bad on instagram i mean that's
the argument it feels like what they're
doing as cover to kind of push this you
need more power to really push well who
do you think the the fat pride activists
are going to love it like that's what
i've been saying there should be no fit
people on here yeah it's disgusting
look at that with a bmi under 94. but
that's how they're gonna that's not real
women
is somehow morbidly obese oh my wife has
gotten that
my wife my wife you were going to make a
point but this is true you've met me i
don't know my point well i've never made
one but you know you've met my wife yes
uh quarterback you met her parents yeah
yeah
naturally tall thin family yeah
naturally all very tall thin get whisked
away in a breeze and she's gotten
comments like we only have sizes for a
real woman like she's six foot she's
tall she's naturally thin you've been
around her we've gone out she eats like
a horse sometimes and a lot of crap too
like sour straws
too she's like eat that she eats like a
normal person should eat well no no she
eats like normal at meals and then
between meals eats all the crap that
none of us could eat fritos are good
yeah exactly like flamin hot cheetos but
the point is people feel totally
comfortable telling my wife like oh yeah
that's just that's just uh that's not
normal that's not a real woman's size
like hold on a second why
you don't think that made her
self-conscious she was self-conscious oh
of course for a long time because people
would make those comments and it wasn't
her fault it's hard for some people to
put on weight i get it you should never
just mock someone because they're
overweight or underweight the problem is
when you have people who want to
eliminate voices who are encouraging
actual fitness or when they want people
to believe that being morbidly obese and
having type 2 diabetes is just as
healthy as not that's not true
okay so in other words they're going to
be really happy about this right now
watch watch i predict it i predict it
right here you can call me to the mat
you are going to see some fat pride
activist models talking about today's
hearing or the findings and see this is
what we were talking about it's
unhealthy that's why you need us that's
why you need us out there and then once
they're done doing their cheer they have
to stop for everything to stop moving
for like 60 seconds no that's why we
need the wide angle lens yes fortunately
home depot doesn't have that sturdy of
rope right
also uh most of them are
they're they're fat they're most of them
are female actors they don't know how to
tie them
you can't do that
they're already going they didn't go to
scouts they're gonna learn sailing
they're busy selling cookies
that's why more men kill themselves they
know how to tie the knots
thank you boy scouts
they say that men kill themselves more
because they have this expectation of
course and the when you look at
something like you know instagram you
have this thing that you have to live up
to and there's so much material it's why
i love tyler one of the quotes from
tyler durden fight club which is like at
what point do your possessions own you
oh right and that eventually becomes why
guys get so depressed and kill
themselves because they don't think they
add up well this is something that i've
talked about a lot and i spoke with my
wife about this
um they they say well you know women
have these these standards of beauty
applied to us first off that happens to
men too that being said something that
that women and this is where you have
people like karen strawn and feminists
who say you know what though we've
overshot it or we're no longer
sympathetic to men the reason that
suicides are overwhelmingly committed by
men you said expectations it's true
every single man knows and here that the
moment you found yourself attracted to
women and your dad had the conversation
about if you want to be a husband is
you're going to have to support them you
didn't have the option so with women
it's like hey you can be a stay-at-home
mom you can work if you want to no one
considers a woman a failure if she's not
a career woman she's a stay-at-home mom
i certainly don't i think you should
have the choice every single man who
does not go to a job is considered a
deadbeat loser that is a different
standard and so if men get laid off from
their job the suicide skyrockets if they
haven't been promoted in their job the
suicide skyrockets you don't see that
same level of suicide tied directly to
the profession of women because it's not
expected as a baseline that you have to
all i'm asking women is that you
understand that men have known since
they were very very young that if they
want a woman in their life if they want
a wife or a woman to be attracted to
them they have to be successful
professionally it's not a choice for men
just to be clear and the suicide rates
reflect that okay
you're right though it really is and no
not interrupt but that's uh just a
perfect way of saying that and and i do
think that women are held to a much
higher standard of beauty that's
completely unfair and i see that also
because they're more beautiful well
they're just i don't even understand the
grossest thing about a woman is that she
likes
[Laughter]
believe that you available would look at
me naked and not just go is this it's
like someone went over the area with a
discolored highlighter yeah there's just
how do i have jaundice just in my penis
there's nothing appealing even gay dudes
it's like they gotta they gotta walk
around to be well they've gotta still
look they gotta still be a little
woman-ish of course and that's the thing
that's so it it's just
men are great i have a point about uh
you know i'm gonna write this down in my
notepad remind me
ah
gay
it's not what you think asian it's
something that i've noticed all right i
guess gation okay
question again they're like how many of
you
how many of you we'll talk about it uh
how many of you have had kovid
you know here's a question how many of
you out there have had covered and then
had coveted again
genuinely one another the numbers are
incredibly sparse and how many of you
have known about something called
natural immunity and do you think look
all i'm arguing is that i think it
should be included when we're talking
about herd immunity when we're talking
about the population being vaccinated i
think that natural immunity should be
taken into the equation that's all i'm
arguing and i would love to see more
research on just how much more
exponentially effective it is but we'll
get to that in a second so last week um
this is scary again australia oh premier
daniel andrews um
gave these words of hope be not afraid
for he brings tidings of great joy to
the people
of australia so first of all uh i can
announce that by friday the 15th of
october
every single authorized worker that is
on that authorised worker list whether
they be in melbourne or in regional
victoria
will need to have had at least one dose
of a covered 19 vaccine
that is if they want to continue working
if there's people that don't want this
mandatory vaccine how do we manage it
well then they won't be going to work
nazi [ __ ]
okay it's very very simple
it's very simple we want to open the
place up you want to i'm not taking
lectures on freedom from people who will
hold all of us back
right we want to be free we're going to
be free we're going to be open isn't
that
getting these vaccinations really
similar to the jews and up we're going
to have
a vaccinated economy
and we're going to lock some people out
because that is far better than locking
everybody down okay a couple of things
first off there are some assumptions
there that are clearly incorrect that
lockdowns work the who said they don't
work the data sets show that they
absolutely do not work i'm not saying
that not locking down shows guaranteed
better outcomes but lockdown certainly
don't let's be very clear about that so
that assumption is well of course our
only option is the lockdown or removal
of people's freedoms right that's what
he's saying and he says i'm not going to
hear i'm not going to hear about freedom
from people who are moving freedom for
th that's very similar to what they did
with the jews now i'm not saying gassing
the jews i'm saying is the lead up which
is we don't want to hear we don't have
to hear complaints about germany from
the people who are the ones destroying
the economy in germany exactly these
people are responsible for it i don't
want to hear about freedom from the
people who are responsible for all of
you removing your freedoms boy is that
scary right and by the way i don't know
if i want to hear a conversation about
freedom that starts authorized workers
right do you hear that that means
there's a list of people that the
government arbitrarily says cannot work
period i think that you'll find the
answers are satisfactory in this spec
crypt for black mirror episode
[Laughter]
so uh and it's i said this it's what's
most scary to me is that no one in the
united states has admonished them when
they they were mad that the taliban
didn't have women in their cabinet yeah
you know i i'm first of all i'm
surprised that you're surprised they
throw ass in a girl's face for trying to
go to a local junior high you're
surprised that the taliban doesn't have
them in positions of unelected office
but no condemnation from our government
here in the united states for the
tyranny that is going on in australia
you don't need a conspiracy you don't
need to talk about what if to me
australia is enough and maybe that's
because dr fauci highest paid one of the
highest paid government officials who's
been completely unelected
has a very similar assessment there are
a number of people for one reason or
other who just do not want to comply and
get vaccinated we've got to get them
vaccinated and hopefully they will do it
willingly
if not there will have to be things that
will essentially put pressure on them
such as you're not going to work in this
particular agency don't use the word
willingly you're not going to be able to
grow this college or this university
unless in fact we're not allowed to
stuff and i believe that once we start
doing that
you will see more and more people
willingly get back
it's not willingly if we take away their
job and ability yes
with a billy club then they will say
please sir give me the shot that
disciplines his children like tommy i
would really like to see you willingly
clean your room otherwise rex is going
to be put in the apartment incinerator
so i hope you willingly clean your room
he willingly took the vaccine after his
head was in the vice and we popped his
eye out yeah let me pull your eye out
for that guy yeah you maybe pop your eye
out for fouchy yeah exactly
willingly i want to hear i want to hear
someone just ask voucher well what do
you define his liberties what do you
define as something upon which you
cannot encroach liberties are something
he takes every time he speaks right yes
exactly true but the good thing is you
know they don't agree on everything the
premiere from australia
because fauci just recently said that he
has always
and i'm kind of foreshadowing he has
always believed there is no time capsule
that could show this is inconsistent no
he has always believed and he's always
been very clear with you that three
doses as opposed to the australian
premier they said you know you need to
have at least one dose yeah that three
doses of the vaccine is the proper
treatment regimen voucher fauci has
always believed this my opinion has
always been well he said i believe
also
a third shot booster for a two dose mrna
should ultimately and will ultimately be
the
proper complete regimen oh i always
advocated it that's see that's again
that's a guy who's never been punched in
the face for lying right now he used the
he used the wrong thing for three and
then it everybody just got shot right
so cool
i
isn't three vaccines the normal number
for all vaccines yes for all vaccines
that's what i thought
wait did i did you you said three yeah
oh no i've always said four oh it's four
it's four
wait wait wait wait uh five
i don't know what he's talking about
this guy is not following the science of
six vaccines i've always believed
everything that guy just says [ __ ]
seven every time abs
six is the magic number here
five by six shots have you any immunity
see in a year all of america is just
going to look like professor clump
getting acupuncture
just fat and stabbed i just
so he's always believed uh three oh wait
a second back in i know we need to go
into the time capsule august
fouchy advocated
for just one treatment unless the
patient was immunocompromised and
require uh
is it inevitable dr valachi that at some
point the not too distant future
everyone is going to need a booster shot
well i think the important thing to
point out is is the differences between
the immune compromised
who really never really got a good
response to begin with so for them it's
more of getting them up to what they
hopefully had gotten the first time
around but we know because of their
immune compromise they don't but right
now at this moment other than the immune
compromised we're not going to be giving
boosters to people sorry pardon me but
[ __ ] this guy
i've always believed three
we it's uh it's it's just we're just a
month away
a month away from when you said the
opposite of that and people will say
well the science has changed no
no you don't get off you don't get off
the marionette hook that easily fauchy
okay because you've now said always
meaning the science has never changed
that's the problem well science changes
but fauci is saying the science has not
changed what point does it become
gasoline you're going awesome i thought
he didn't say
three because i've always said this then
the defense is the signs changed fauci
has undercut that defense by saying the
science has never changed i've always
said that and no one call is there a hey
can i can we search by the way can
people let me know let me know in chat
is there a snopes is there a politifact
on fouchy saying i've always believed
that it was three shots
please let me know i think that's where
it's it's where it's like well i've
always believed but that hasn't been
official policy
do you think he'll stick to one story
once he figures out the internet exists
because that's how they act like they
don't know there could be any improv you
can't rewind the internet well they're
so insulated they're they're so
surrounded by people
who
just never say
huh
well no they're not none of the
interviewers are ever going to challenge
him because the media is just carrying
his water and saying oh well he's the
scientist we have to do the sun well
we'll get to that in a minute sorry i
almost almost talked about sanjay gupta
and that makes me throw up well don't do
that i'm not going to that makes us all
throw up we've been talking about you'll
throw up and then he's going to throw up
it's going to be a peristaltic chain
reaction and i throw up on this show a
lot he does yeah that's true we've been
talking about boosters for months this
is not something that is a new thing
it's not a to be fair he could be
confused because he needs it to fill out
the children's place matt well that's
true that's true
he's also not seen a page how am i
supposed to write on can someone get me
a i've always said i need all right
three boosted thank you three three
cheers i didn't get my hologram with the
grand slam breakfast i want three
crayons that's a throwback sorry three
multiple colors i always get the two i
would get the black one
black and the white it's a shade it's
not a color it's a shade
ain't anything white what a piece of
[ __ ] okay uh
also it gets worse
sorry for my language i just i i wish i
i just you know look thoroughly don't
worry lord forgive me it's wrong to hate
so following the very first vaccines
god's like listen
[Laughter]
but no one's getting punished for it
either
look at look at the tagline or look at
the lower third right ah they just
changed we'll talk about it i'm just too
nervous that we'll get in trouble for
something they say that we're not alone
okay all right we'll talk about it later
but we will talk about our mug club uh
it gets worse this was this august
following the first vaccines
administered in december 2020 fauci said
that one dose of the vaccine would be
effective even against at that point the
new alpha variant from the uk this is
when we first so he's always believed
three we just showed you in august he
believes two now let's go back to when
the vaccines are first released i want
to ask you about the uk
mutation and and you know we call it
that except of course we ask about your
pugsley adam's haircut
and so what i'm wondering is how likely
is it
in your mind that she's already killed
that guy like 11 times already in the
united states
i would not be surprised that if it
already is at low levels in other
countries that have not yet detected it
including canada including the united
states what is the rationale here it's
suggestive that given the rate of spread
in the uk
that this mutation might be responsible
for the increased spread which means it
increases the transmissibility of the
virus
that could be true we're going to assume
that it is
what we know it doesn't do it does not
appear
to increase the virulence of the virus
namely making it a more serious or
deadly virus
and it doesn't appear at all
to interfere with the protective effect
of a vaccine okay so he wasn't right
about that
now study from the new england journal
of medicine compared the efficacy of one
dose of the physio vaccine to two doses
when treating the uk alpha variant one
dose was 48 two doses ninety three
percent
one dose three
two
people say follow the science how do
they follow the science and how do they
follow the science that changes if
they're then told that the science has
never changed
what that does is just tell you that
even if you're one of the hyper
progressives who believes that you're
following the science and science
changes all fauci is doing is saying
that you're wrong when he says i've
always believed this it means whatever
you've done you're wrong because he's
never wrong
let's just be clear about that when he
the science didn't change with the masks
the ppe shortage
he basically said well i lied because i
wanted to make sure that nurses had the
mess so i wasn't wrong about the science
now he's saying it's like well you said
one you said one dose was enough then he
said two doses and less is it no i've
always said three right and no one in
the media just says uh no you said two
that would screw his whole propaganda
plan right there right and if you are
willing to accept i lied for the
betterment of the people i lied to make
sure that we had a a better supply of
ppe i lied to make sure more people got
vaccinated i'm not saying he said that
but i'm saying if he if you accept that
you'll accept anything that he says and
he's like oh well i just did it for the
good of the people
if you go back through history every
single time these things spin out of
control it's for the better of the
people like oh i'm doing it for the
betterment of all the people australia
we're doing it for the people who got
vaccinated right we're doing it for you
joe biden we're doing it so that we can
reopen the economy i know there's
unvaccinated people out there and
they're holding us back jim pasaki
columbia professors i'm doing it to make
sure that we don't get any students
infected here in school jim jones in
california right well no and then you
get people who really do look like a
reincarnation of the devil that are the
that's the head the governor of
california coming out and saying oh yeah
every single kid has to as soon as the
shots are available to go to class live
you have to get the shot every single
one gavin newsom just he just looks evil
but that's what you get when you believe
the lie and go it's okay to lie it's
okay to lie as long as it's for my good
yeah well i have a question this is just
a a question
so youtube this is not a statement all
right i just have an honest question i
want to ask could it be
that the amount of alcohol that we're
using on a constant basis as well as a
vaccine that hasn't been around that
long could be
creating the variance or making a virus
stronger that's all i'm asking is it
possible what you eat alcohol in
combination with it well i think the
fact that when you cover yourself
constantly in hand sanitizer oh i
thought you'd been drinking yeah yeah oh
no no i yeah i know i wish
[Laughter]
dave's like i've been dousing it with
i've been dousing it with canadian
whiskey for years
it only takes me a thimble and i'm
hammered
no schlitz with a vaccine that's why my
brother's never got it no i uh i love
him i'm kidding um
no no look and then i'm it's not an
honest question a lot of scientists have
asked the question too can someone bring
this up because i want to make sure i'm
not incorrect there were more deaths uh
i don't know if it was in the uk this
august than last august it was either
more deaths or hospitalizations or cases
this august than last august when there
weren't people vaccinated so look i know
you can say it's the delta variant i
believe it comes from the uk numbers
they release them every thursday um and
because they have socialized health care
and there's no right to privacy there
they have more damage
so again like okay at that point then
the argument gets to well it's because
of the delta variant and then they say
well a high percentage of people who get
infected it's because it's a high
percentage of the population so natural
and then they act like so naturally
they're going to be a higher percentage
in whichever example is being used
whether it's israel or australia or
whatever so naturally a higher
percentage if more people no no if a
vaccine works it's not naturally it's
going to parallel the percentage because
then it means that it's it's not
effective and there are some people
who've said because uh
because of how viruses mutate mutate and
these are doctors and i don't want to
speak out of turn but viruses tend to
become more transmissible and less
deadly today's flu is effectively a
remnant of the spanish flu people need
to understand that viruses continually
mutate it's in the best interest of the
virus there are exceptions to the rule
it's in the best interest of the virus
to not destroy all of its hosts so
typically we see them become
more contagious more transmissible but
less deadly on a percentage basis
and if you have people who have let's
say protection against one one kind of
the virus one variant of the virus so
that virus can't live with those people
but the virus is mutating seeking more
hosts you may end up with a variant that
can somehow pen and then you end up
according to mayo clinic i think it was
the modern pfizer vaccine it was 42
effective against the delta variant it
was like 90 against the alpha variant
yeah you end up with variance look when
you understand how viruses work and
there are doctors who talk about this
what happens they're banned from youtube
they've been from twitter they're banned
from facebook i'm not saying that's the
case i'm saying historically that's how
viruses tend to mutate the right
exceptions well and and we've known this
for a long time when you don't kill a
virus when you allow the virus to live
but you do something to make it less
less deadly right which is a good thing
that's that's a very positive step
forward to take or to decrease severe
kind of cases of this for
hospitalizations it allows the virus to
continue to live in the host right and
it gives it the opportunity to mutate
and to be more transmissible any virus
that we've dealt with has done this
that's why most of the time when you get
a vaccine it actually takes that out
right otherwise it's a treatment that
doesn't necessarily kill the virus
there's benefits to that but there's
also this kind of consequence that we're
not really it's the same thing like with
the flu shot right you don't get like
you get measles vaccines you get
it's a flu shot because it's a different
variant that comes back of the flu often
every year and so it's a yearly shot and
they're taking a wild guess at it like
guys yeah these three are that tend to
be the jerks we're going to have to
target we think so but uh it's okay we
all accept that we're gonna be holding a
bloody arm from someone who's untrained
at your local walgreens right and by the
way i would be surprised i'm sorry dave
just one final thing on this i this is
brand new when this stuff started
happening i don't expect our experts to
be like yeah we've got this nailed
everything it's brand new we didn't know
this was coming it's okay if you have an
oh crap moment we didn't see that coming
i would believe you more if you were
honest some of my colleagues did have an
oh soil moment but i always believe it
was three oh yeah three being the magic
number of doses the magic number of
doses having been three
days no more no less well yeah i don't
know where this came from like how many
i guess how many viruses are we aware of
that were man-made in in the sense of
like this where like somebody had like a
spider monkey sandwich then went on a
plane or whatever the hell happened in
wuhan so but it was a bat day but i'm
sorry a bat uh a vampire bat it was like
that churro yeah yeah
but how many times have we released a
virus
is this a first a second like i really
i'm i'm honestly i don't know i don't
know the number i don't know
we don't even know where it's come from
right because ebola wasn't a man-made
virus right uh i don't believe so i
don't believe that people it was ebola's
been around for a long time and then
there was you know you had there were
different versions of sars like the bird
flu there was right yeah there was all
stars
well that's the big concern like are we
are we going to inadvertently let's just
stay inadvertently are we going to
inadvertently release something that is
very deadly now in china we can we can
assume motive maybe we can we can have a
conspiracy theory about it or we can say
they had bad procedures and they didn't
follow them very well or we should have
been doing gain of function research
rand paul had some great questions about
that right eventually that's the fear is
that we're going to do it to ourselves
right right we're going to make a
mistake and it's going to get out and
we're going to have a problem with it
following the science without any moral
parameters is dangerous well it's dr
moreau right or jeff jeff goldblum
finds a way
yeah so oh no that's a good point uh i
don't know how many of them are but i
know that ebola was a you know close to
a half death rate that was very very
different oh yeah in liberia anyway
specifically oh no it was really bad it
was really bad um by the way that now
this brings us to natural immunity and
that's why i've been asking you if
you've ever had if you've had covet if
you got it again uh the master of
science dr fauci
was questioning natural immunity at
every turn here you go it is an
assumption
that is okay
to get infected and to get mild to
moderate disease as long as you don't
wind up in the hospital and die
and i have to be open and honest i
reject that i get calls all the time
people say i've already had covid i'm
protected and now the study says maybe
even more protected than the vaccine
alone
should they also get the vaccine how do
you make the case to them
we have it now you know that's a really
good point sanjay i don't have a really
firm answer for you on that that's
something that we're going to have to
discuss regarding the durability of this
one
one thing the paper from israel didn't
tell you is whether or not as high as
the protection is with natural infection
what's the durability compared to the
durability of a vaccine so it is
conceivable if you got infected you're
protected but you may not be protected
for an indefinite period of time
okay uh you know let's go uh angela have
those numbers we'll go back to those
numbers in a little bit because really
quickly i want to rattle through this uh
we have a study to substantiate what
we're about to show but just last night
project veritas a friend there james
o'keefe
you can go and watch it on their social
media channels as well as their website
they released undercover video with
scientists from pfizer saying that your
antibodies are more effective more
durable than their own vaccine when it's
not fouchy on a quadrant
this is what the scientists at pfizer
say carl is an experienced biochemist
advisor with a history of working the
pharmaceutical industry nick admits to
our undercover journalists that those
who've had covid have stronger immunity
than those who've received the pfizer
covid vaccine when somebody is naturally
um amused
like they got coping
scientists
like not better but more antibodies
against
so it's just one antibody against one
specific part of the virus
when you actually get the virus
you're going to start producing
antibodies against like multiple pieces
of virus and
not only just like the outside portion
like the inside porcelain the actual
virus so your antibodies are probably
better
guy who looks like he sells cocaine
that's mostly baby laxative
probably more than the vaccine
protected
most likely for longer
since there was a natural response we're
like bred and taught to be like
like
vaccine is safer than than actually
getting coco you cannot like talk about
this
in public if you have antibodies booked
up like you should be able to prove that
you have those built up i mean i still
feel like i work for like an evil
corporation we're trying to
keep track of everyone that's been
vaccinated versus the census of how many
people
are actually reported basically our
organization is run on profit money now
right now we're seeing
an increase in the delta variant
mostly not because of
the variant
because of
immune
they're
basically their antibodies are waning
um so they're
they're still protected but not at that
95 percent
efficacy
it's more like
70 so you're being you're
protected
most likely for laundry
since there was a natural response
that scientists from fish are going to
go to project veritas.com brave to
support them uh that's the scientists at
pfizer saying you're protected for
longer and remember when i was
interviewing people on the street
quarterbacker we'll have this up
sometime this week maybe thursday they
one lady said uh it was two two asian
ladies and they said well we recently
had the vaccine and uh i'm recently
immune i said well what do you mean you
said you have the vaccine but you
recently i mean well i had covet i said
okay so let me ask you and you'll see
this video i said let me ask you when if
do you think they should be considered
people who don't want to get the vaccine
if they have natural immunity and she
said well no because natural immunity it
doesn't work against the variants and it
only lasts for like three months i said
actually
from the little science that's been
conducted we're allowed to discuss the
exact opposite is true no no you don't
know anything she says through her kn95
mask that she got at
bucky's so there's a 700 000 person
study not just pfizer saying this from
israel that shows natural immunity is 20
well i don't know i was going to say 27
times stronger that people are 27 times
less likely to get reinfected from
natural immunity than people who had
done the full two course treatment
that's why now in israel you're not even
considered vaccinated unless you're
doing the the third booster right
exactly and that just happened at like
the stroke of midnight two days ago i
believe it's like boom you're
unvaccinated guess what if you're an
australian that happens you're not going
to work tomorrow right you actually get
the booster did you say angela we
brought we have those numbers we uh
it looks like we do i just had them sent
in okay so we have these numbers this is
one thing where people just look and i
understand i'm not aesthetician and i
understand that people will say well
actually you have to look at the death
rate for okay all i understand all that
can be taken into account however if the
argument now is that this first this was
a pandemic of the unvaccinated and now
it's well actually it just it can affect
the unvaccinated and the vaccinated so i
don't feel safe so i need a mask so i
don't really know what they're saying
now however if this is a problem
exclusively on the of the unvaccinated
of course we would have higher total
deaths for example
in august of this year compared to
august of 2020.
hmm
that does look like it's higher wow
is that august of this year in august of
2020. i don't think that's uh so the
we're trying to find it the one to the
left is may 2020
over there and then the other sheet you
have
yeah it's hard to see a side by side
here where's where's uh yeah we need to
see the august numbers
they just released
they just released these numbers uh they
released them on thursday
and i say that because that's when we
had a recent search you can see it right
there so the dip on the left side of the
screen that's august if they hover over
it that's august of 2020 and that not
the big spike but the other spike there
should be around august of 2021 so it
looks like the highest first year okay
so it's higher yeah so higher in 2021
that's what according to your point i
was saying you should expect them to be
lower you should expect the opposite
right
it's significantly higher bring up that
last one again that's the last graph
yeah yeah now that we understand because
again keep in mind i'm looking at a
small monitor so the dip the first dip
is august 2020. so and by the way just
to be clear this is the hospital
admissions graph okay the hospital
admissions i'm pretty sure that the i
don't know there were a couple of graphs
that actually were pretty similar but
again the numbers there should be no
number bring it up for tomorrow yeah
there's no number that should be higher
in august of this year compared to
august of last year considering that
yeah 50 is it well is this exclusive in
uk are numbers in the united states
considering that a huge portion a
majority of the population
are vaccinated yeah so in any way in
other words you would have to look at
the total number of unvaccinated people
this is something that just you you
don't need to
be
a scientist just to say something
doesn't pass the sniff test yeah look
if this were a vaccine that worked just
as effectively or more effectively as
natural immunity and if fauci actually
believed that the entire time
that you needed three shots we wouldn't
be in this absolute quagmire at this
point yeah the issue is they haven't
been forthcoming they've they haven't
changed the science
they haven't they've ghosted previous
science that's the issue you can't go
and find the science right now try and
find the science mayo clinic
large scale clinical study on vaccine
efficacy you'd have to type in four five
six cross reference words to find it
yeah now fine now just type in fouchy
natural immunity and you know video
after video after video of him saying
well we don't know that's the point
right now is they remove science that is
no longer convenient i absolutely
believe that science is developing yeah
well i absolutely believe that we should
follow the changes in science wow of
course keeping our eye on what's most
important are fundamental liberties you
just can't erase all of the science that
you were espousing previously right and
i the question that i want to ask dr
fauci from that last interview sanjay
just said well it's uh there's there's a
lot more from just having natural
immunity that's great and he's like well
yeah but we don't know how long it lasts
is it longer than six months
that's i is it longer than four months
hey let me ask you seen that drop how
many people who have tested positive for
covid have recontracted covet now how
many people who've been vaccinated have
caught covet there you go there's your
answer you can look it up yourself
because i don't want to get in trouble
for posting the truth because that's not
science it'll hit you in the face like a
sledgehammer be sure to put on your
mouth guard we have to uh go to michael
but first let me show you actually we'll
be playing on my club we're gonna be
playing bad movie lines a lot of people
don't know what we do sometimes we'll be
playing this with you we have a teaser
[Music]
i was given paranormal powers as a child
i've hacked into just about all the
information i need
they have no idea
no more books you were given a power
others want to take this from me
i knew i loved you when i was eight
years old should i be afraid
should we be afraid
i'm not ready for this
you're going to get yourself killed
but you should be scared because it is
the truth
you want to get out of here but you
can't see what's about to happen
[Music]
they don't pay me enough for this all
right youtube we're gonna go play bad
movie lines or watch this testimony
depending on what people in the chat say
uh youtube piss off see you tomorrow
do